now that morbius is a movie star you
might find yourself wondering just who
is this classic marvel foe you may know
his spider-man connection but what about
his bond with she-hulk here's everything
you need to know about morbius the
living vampire
nowadays in marvel comics morbius often
walks the line between a good guy and a
bad guy if you're getting mugged and the
living vampire happens to walk by he'll
probably step in and help but he's also
likely to get himself a snack at the
same time when he first showed up in
1971's amazing spider-man number 101
however there was no anti-hero nonsense
going on morbius was a stone-cold killer
amazing spider-man number 101 was
memorable for a few reasons most notably
it was the first issue of the comic that
wasn't written by stan lee roy thomas
took over writing duties and lee had
left thomas with a bit of a cliffhanger
peter parker had suddenly found himself
with six arms so in this comic
spider-man seeks out the nobel
prize-winning dr morbius hoping that he
can find a cure in the doctor's research
instead he finds a blood-sucking vampire
with a mean streak both thomas and jerry
conway who wrote morbius's subsequent
appearances in marvel team-up told back
issue in 2009 that they never imagined
morbius would go on to become a dark
hero conway said i more or less thought
of him as a one-shot villain they both
agree though that the foundation for
something more was there in morbius's
first appearance conway said both sides
of him were always there he was always
supposed to be a fairly sympathetic
character
some fans believe that morbius was
rendered a living vampire as a sneaky
way of getting around the comics code
and that his subsequent popularity
helped force changes to the code itself
the comics code was a self-imposed
industry standard that among other
things banned any depictions of the
undead morbius's living status was
marvel's loophole or so the legend told
the truth is that morbius's creation was
actually a response to the comics code
loosening of its rules about vampire
zombies and other undead creatures at
the same time stan lee wanted to
capitalize on the code's newer more
liberal attitude roy thomas has said
that he and lee first discussed using
dracula as the villain in amazing
spider-man number 101
children of the night
what music they need but lee wanted a
costumed villain instead ironically
while morbius didn't create any friction
with the comics code years later another
artist claimed to have locked horns with
the code over his work on the character
penciller ron wagner worked on the first
14 issues of morbius the living vampire
and apparently got in a heap of trouble
for his use of sexually explicit
drawings in the comic
while morbius's living status was not a
sneaky way around the comics code it was
an important aspect of his character for
one thing it allowed him to remain in
the marvel universe for longer than his
undead contemporaries in 1983's dr
strange number 62 the sorcerer supreme
uses his magic to boost the montessie
formula killing marvel's version of
dracula and the rest of the world's
vampires eventually dracula would return
in the series night stalkers but that
comeback was a whole decade in the
making and in the meantime one vampire
remained completely unaffected by any of
it morbius because morbius's condition
has nothing to do with traditional
vampirism doctor strange's war on
dracula has no impact on dr morbius
beyond freeing up the playing field from
competition anyway
according to morbius co-creator roy
thomas the conception of the living
vampire involved a marriage of various
campy science fiction references though
not all of them were intentional
morbius's name came from the character
dr edward morbius from the 1956 film
forbidden planet apparently though this
wasn't a conscious choice and thomas
didn't realize that that's where he had
lifted the name from until after the
comic was already on the racks thomas
has also revealed that the inspiration
for morbius's origin as a creature of
science fiction rather than fantasy came
from a film he had seen in his youth one
in which radiation not magic turned a
character into a vampire during his
interview with back issue however he
could not remember the film's name while
neither film fits exactly with thomas's
memory two films released in 1957 just a
year after forbidden planet could fit
the bill of science created vampires not
of this earth features an alien who
disguises himself as human and drains
victims of their blood the same year saw
the release of the vampire about a man
who unwittingly contracts vampirism
after ingesting pills made of vampire
bad blood
one of the most important stories in
morbius's history involves a weird
violent court scene in the pages of
savage she-hulk temporarily cured of his
condition dr morbius is working on ways
to help lawyer jennifer walters better
known as she-hulk from dying
unfortunately for her morbius is due to
stand trial for his many crimes walters
subsequently defends morbius during the
trial and uses a bizarre method to
protect her client to prove morbius was
not in control of his actions while he
was a vampire walters brings a pair of
rabbits into the court and feeds one of
them the formula that transformed him
predictably the rabbit immediately goes
full holy grail and kills its furry
mates
walters succeeds in getting morbius's
charges reduced and the living vampire's
transformation from outright villain to
morally ambiguous anti-hero is complete
the morbius of the ultimate universe was
introduced in ultimate spider-man number
95. this version of morbius is more
connected to the vampires of his world
than his marvel earth prime counterpart
he's a more traditional undead vampire
who even tells spider-man that he is the
son of dracula ironically though more
attached to the world of the undead than
the original the ultimate morbius is not
only not a villain but actually spends
much of his time hunting his vampiric
brethren while marvel officially nailed
the coffin on its ultimate line of
comics in 2015 with the secret wars
tie-in miniseries ultimate end the
ultimate line's impact on marvel's film
adaptations can't be ignored nick fury
was first drawn as samuel jackson in
ultimates six years before the actor
appeared in iron man black widow and
hawkeye being a part of the original
avengers lineup is an ultimate holdover
too as is captain america's world war ii
era outfit and the alien chitari while
the origin of the character in morbius
fits more with the original marvel
version you could argue some aspects are
inspired by the ultimate line including
his more heroic nature and his conflict
with fellow vampire milo
if it had been up to screenwriter and
director david s goyer the living
vampire's first big screen appearance
would likely have predated the mcu by a
half decade at least in a deleted scene
found on the dvd of 1998's blade a
mysterious figure in a dark trench coat
watches from a nearby rooftop as blade
and karen emerge triumphant from their
conflict with lamagra goyer the film's
writer has since confirmed the figure
was morbius and claims that had goyer
gone on to direct blade 2 morbius would
have been the villain for the sequel
instead guillermo del toro directed
blade 2 and the story was altered
jettisoning him all together it would no
doubt be fascinating to sidestep into an
alternate reality where goyer got to
write his version of blade 2. morbius
was a character full of potential for
that series particularly if gwyer meant
to stay true to the tragic and more
sympathetic nature of the character
deacon frost the villain of blade was a
ruthless killer and the villains of
blade 2 weren't much better a more
tortured and conflicted antagonist may
have made for an intriguing contrast
morpheus is far from the only marvel
character based on a classic kind of
monster though it took until 2021 to
reveal a connection between the living
vampire and calvin zabo also known as mr
hyde agents of shield fans may remember
kyle mclaughlin had a recurring role as
cal on season two of the series
[Music]
oh
and there goes the feeling in my legs in
the comics hyde is a genuine powerhouse
able to hold his own against earth's
mightiest heroes in the 2021 one-shot
morbius bond of blood it's revealed that
morbius and zabo have known each other
since before either were transformed
into their more monstrous selves morbius
strikes a deal with zabo in the hopes of
saving a child's life but as you might
predict things don't exactly work out
well more recently a further connection
has been revealed between morbius's
condition and another monstrous marvel
scientist in 2022's amazing spider-man
number 92 kurt connors becomes infected
with the vampire's condition the
development sends conor's on a rampage
and renders him more dangerous than ever
spidey misty knight and colleen wing
then recruit morbius to help him stop
conor's and cure him of his disease
for much of his comic book existence
morbius has walked a morally ambiguous
line he usually fights on the side of
good but he's a lot less picky about the
methods he employs than other heroes but
in 2022 morbius pole vaulted out of the
anti-hero zone into outright villainous
territory in recent years michael
morbius has continued to search for a
cure to his condition when he surfaces
again in 2022's amazing spider-man
number 77 his illness has worsened
sending him on a near mindless rampage
the ben reilly spider-man confronts him
when he finds morbia standing over the
bodies of a half dozen or so victims the
vampire attacks spidey without
provocation and the issue ends with
morbius sinking his teeth into riley's
neck with riley weakened by morbius's
attack it's up to misty knight and
colleen wing to take morbius down in the
following issue unfortunately the beyond
corporation takes the opportunity to
experiment on morbius against his will
on the bright side they stabilized his
condition in the process so that when
he's revived in amazing spider-man
number 92 he's back to his old self
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]